on va parler d'ailleurs les géants de la
techno sont-ils surévalué sur les
marchés sommes-nous en pleine bulle
boursière on n'a pas souvent vous savez
de cette fameuse bulle boursière on va
discuter derrière avec jean paul
giacometti qui est gestionnaire de
portefeuille chez claret bonjour
monsieur giacometti bonsoir
quelle est votre analyse sur la
situation est ce qu'on est en train
effectivement de vivre une bulle leur
sport mais pour être dans une bulle il
faut être dans des niveaux d'évaluation
très élevé et un niveau d'assurance très
élevé donc à mon avis on est
définitivement dans l'entrée d'une de la
sq à venir demain dans six mois ou dans
1 ans je ne le sais pas oui c'est ça
parce que c'est pas exactement quand
elle va éclater cette de l'aube j'ai
l'impression que les gens la maison les
boursicoteurs les investisseurs bresse à
avoir une date précise d'un calendrier
mais est ce qu'on peut savoir à peu près
là où et pour éclater mais la pilule est
normalement dans l'histoire il s'éclate
à cause d'un événement
donc ça prend un événement déclencheur
et cet événement déclencheur peut être
plusieurs items je suis pas si vous
voulez les aborder maintenant ça pète
orr actuellement donc elle n'a pas
daigné videmment donc qu'un impact la
sueur sur les différents titres ben
laden élément déclencheur pour que celle
de l'exploser mon avis on a deux que je
peux voir mais souvent on peut même
venir voir le premier à mon avis ça
serait la venue d'un vaccin
la journée où il annonce que le vaccin
est disponible et qu' il peut être
utilisé
ça va être la fin d'un espoir et le
retour à la réalité comme vous l'avez
très bien annoncé au début de l'émission
c'est pas une petite récession que c'est
pas quelque chose dont on tourne
quadruple c'est fini on en parle où ça
peut être carrément les élections
américaines centre de la politique il ya
des partis qui veulent taxer tout ce qui
fait des profits et individus et
compagnie il va falloir payer l'argent
qui était imprimé donc ça peut être deux
événements qui pourrait changer le cours
des choses parce qu'actuellement c'est
sam hambourg vient tout juste d'en
parler les résultats dégâts face c'est
quand même assez impressionnant monsieur
giacometti facebook amazon ont doublé
leurs profits c'est du concret cela
c'est du concret en termes de profil ne
sait ce qu'ils font des profits
mais vous savez l'environnement de rêve
aussi pour ces compagnies
vous ferez enfermé presque tous leurs
compétiteurs vous forcer tout le monde à
rester à la maison donc c'est la
situation idéale brute mais on s'entend
c'est pour les profits qui compte c'est
combien de fois vous payez les profits
ouais parce qu'on al'impression un peu
là que la pandémie c'est la tempête
parfaite le pauvre pour les gaffes
oui tout à fait tout à fait puis ça peut
continuer encore là c'est pas la fin
mais des signes qui montrent que selon
l'histoire ça peut être des signes qui
montrent que l'on approche entre conte
et on est dans une zone grise sont les
palois alors il y en a qui compare la
situation actuelle à la bulle techno
vous savez qui avait explosé donc au
début des années 2000 mais vous vous
reculez un petit peu plus loin alors là
pour les investisseurs c'est intéressant
vous fait un parallèle avec les
effectifs hefti expliqué moussa oui
parce que les années 2000 les compagnies
n'avaient pas de profit c'était tout
simplement de l'air basé sur le nombre
de fois de france
mais si on utilise ces paramètres le
nasdaq y pas encore quadruples est
aujourd'hui skin à mon avis tu n'arrives
reprendre que pas dans un environnement
proche tandis que dans les années
soixante douze il y avait déjà plein et
effectivement en fait c'est une poignée
de compagnies qu'on disait dans les amis
de jean desailly monsieur jack bouin
exactement compte c'est que et qui
trouvent pas ils font de l'argent c'est
l'avenir you coca cola désignés par le
roi et rocks avant pour ceux qui s'en
souviennent
alors c'était ce type d'entreprise là
les gens investissent et soudainement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais c'est que
pour on disait aux gens ont investi les
yeux fermés c'est l'avenir et ces
compagnies là croyez le ou non coca cola
était comme 50 60 fois les profits avant
même 80 mais moins cher est autour de 30
40 pour les profils salée jusqu'à 90
fois les profits et la crise est là et
on se rappelle aussi que la crise
pétrolière à ce moment-là et fluence est
ce que c'était l'événement déclencheur
tout à fait c'est l'événement
déclencheur où les consommateurs se sont
fait couper les jambes si on peut dire
que couper le souffle ça serait
peut-être mieux et
ces compagnies là on continue à faire
des profits c'est pas plus qu'aux filles
ont disparu même que coca cola leurs
profits augmenter mais là leur ratio est
tombé de 60 fois les profits à 15 fois
les profits dans ce temps là le marché à
19 fois les profits à un départ à
soixante fois ces compagnies là attirer
tout l'argent des investisseurs donc
faut faire attention il faut regarder
aussi la croissance fulgurante des
gaffes a donc lors des dernières années
est ce que vous voyez une chute qui
pourrait être aussi brutale que leur
ascension
mais les gaffes en ce moment tous ces
titres qui n'est plus que l'on peut
ajouter paypal et tous ces autres types
de croissance se transigent en trente
fois à 150 fois les profits même avec
les profits qui vient d'annoncer parce
que les ventes augmentent mais les
profits augmentent beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins vite
donc oui d'oubli montrent aussi mais là
vous avez vous venez de mentionner
facebook avec 3 millions d'utilisateurs
oui en nocturne de comptes peut-être
mais ça fait quand même beaucoup de gens
c'était difficile de continuer ce rythme
de croissance à moins nette que des
martiens deviennent mans on est dans une
zone où les gens se disent et sur celles
à venir
il faut que j'en achète et je dois vous
avouer nous on détient facebook ont un
facebook a pas sonné deux moins cher si
on peut dire à 30 fois les profits
si vous aller du côté d'amazon à 150
fois puis même chauffé failli oublier ça
il ya même pas de profit encore donc ça
veut pas dire qu'ils réussiront pas mais
ça veut dire que les chances d'accidents
sont élevées web yeux un ralentissement
aussi du nombre d'utilisateurs qu'est-ce
qu'on fait d'ailleurs avec facebook vous
êtes nous on en donne du côté de ben
nous on garde facebook on garde facebook
pour l'instant c'est une plateforme qui
avec plusieurs plateformes et projette
facebook les ont plusieurs
de même champ d'activité qui permet de
main ce qui est drôle pour marquer
s'annonce facebook les revenus
augmentent à cause d'un ptz gougaud les
revenus diminuent à cause d'un retard 1
mais voyez vous un peu d'inconstance 8
go go il faut cliquer il faut aller voir
c'est beaucoup de voyages leur terrain
mais c'est pour dire qu'ils ont le vent
dans les voiles en ce moment ça va très
bien et puis nous on est plus concentré
sur facebook mais ce que je vais paris
la mairie
on a dû non pas nécessairement qu'un
côté on pourrait donner aux
investisseurs aux boursicoteurs le par
rapport par rapport aux gaffes qui
aurait conseillé également aussi général
avec les marchés actuellement mais il ya
beaucoup d'investissements si vous
regardez côte d'ans qui a qui en ont
simplement qu'ils vont aller faire un
mythe une partie du médicament qui va
supposément une entrevue depuis le site
passe de 2 dollars à 52 30 pc transige
neuf fois la valeur de la compagnie dans
la même journée c'est beaucoup de
spéculations en notant à ce printemps et
un nombre record de conteste le courtage
à escompte ouvert theckly casino est
enfermé les gens qui se disent ah je
reçus un peu d'argent je vais le faire
fructifier
ben ça fait beaucoup de spéculation fait
que mon conseil c'est ya juste une chose
de ce que rien sur ce traité à savoir
conseille également jean-paul giacometti
gestionnaire de portefeuille chez que la
reine merci beaucoup merci à vous